in the frontline city of micolaith the
maternity hospital tries to operate as
normally as the war will allow
tamara kravchuk is close to giving birth
the day before a different part of this
hospital was hit by a shell but nobody
was hurt
over time every day you get used to it
more and more especially when the
explosions are somewhere far away it
seems they are in another country
in the western city of lev another
clinic this one treating children with
critical heart conditions
this unit has just been moved from the
capital kiev
it's part of a national initiative to
relocate essential services and
companies away from the fighting in the
east to the relative safety of the west
we are saving kids who have critical
heart problems who would die without
operations and of course each child is
important
there are hundreds of them so it's very
stressful
live and other towns and cities in the
west have been dealing with a surge in
newcomers since the start of the war
many more institutions and businesses
are planning to make the same move west
like this hospital most say eventually
they'll move back east again just when
no one can tell
back in the maternity unit in macaulay
tamara has given birth to a baby
daughter
i hope our children won't see these
crazy sins and everything will be good
there is no other way a few minutes old
and delivered into a world her mother
could not have imagined just a few weeks
ago
rob mcbride al jazeera level